Speaker 1: Congresswoman Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez
is calling for the impeachment of Supreme Court
Justice Clarence Thomas over his failure to
disclose luxury trips paid for by a Republican
megadonor. We told you last week how ProPublica
broke this story that Thomas has been in the
pocket of right wing billionaire Harlan Crow for
decades. Thomas has vacationed on Crows 162 foot
super yacht and flown on his Bombardier Global
5000 jet, which would have cost half a million
dollars if the money had come from Thomas and he
had chartered it himself. The trips put Thomas in
contact with corporate executives and political
activists, violating federal disclosure laws and
long standing norms for a judge's conduct. This is
a very violation of his ethical obligations as a
justice, and he disregarded federal disclosure
laws. We were wondering if Thomas was going to
ever say anything at all about this because
he so rarely comments on anything before the
public. But I suppose the scandal was bad enough
that he at least felt the need to say something
about it. He said, quote. Harland and Cathy Crow
are among our dearest friends and we have been
friends for over 25 years. As friends do, we have
joined them on a number of family trips during
the more than quarter century. We have known them.
Early in my tenure at the court, I sought guidance
from my colleagues and others in the judiciary and
was advised that this sort of personal hospitality
from close personal friends who did not have
business before the court was not reportable.
I have endeavored to follow that counsel
throughout my tenure and have always sought
to comply with the disclosure guidelines.
These guidelines are now being changed as
the Committee of the Judicial Conference
responsible for financial disclosure for
the entire federal judiciary just this past
month announced new guidance. And it is,
of course, my intent to follow this guidance in
the future. Now, if you're as jaded and skeptical
when it comes to politics as I am, you may
think that this is where the story ends,
because Thomas is basically never held
accountable for anything, including the
Anita Hill allegations, including the conflicts of
interest that he had with his wife, Jenny Thomas,
being a far right activist and a complete Kool-Aid
drinker when it comes to the conspiracy theories
about voter fraud in the 2020 election. It seems
like at this point it's only Representative
Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez who wants to do anything
substantial to hold Thomas accountable for these
ethical violations. She tweeted her support for
impeaching Thomas late last week. And here she
is yesterday on CNN's State of the Union with Dana
Bash laying out why she believes the. That Thomas
needs to be removed from his post over this.
Speaker 5: And I believe that it is the House's
responsibility to pursue that investigation in the
form of impeachment. Well, let me ask you. I mean,
you know full well that the House is now run by
Republicans. How are you going to move what you're
calling for articles of impeachment through
a House that is run by Republicans? You know,
I think it's a it's a there is the question of
the politics of what we are doing, and there's the
question of the recourse and the accountability
and the structures of what we are doing. I admit
it is a it is very difficult to see a path in
a Republican Party that refuses to hold itself
accountable and in fact, breaches the law itself.
Speaker 1: Now, of course, we run into the
reality that Republicans control the House
of Representatives, and there's basically no
world in which Kevin McCarthy decides to introduce
articles of impeachment against Clarence Thomas,
at least not over this issue. But I do believe
it's good that there are calls for him to face an
ethics violation, calls for him to step down, and
this call for him to be impeached. I do wonder,
however, if AOC is the right person to do this,
since she's such a polarizing figure and so many
people are just going to write this off
as a radical leftist trying to attack a
well-established Supreme Court justice over an
issue that maybe not impeachable in their eyes.
But even though she seems to recognize
that she's still deciding to be the one
voice of reason in this matter, the one person
calling for impeachment and saying, you know,
if no one else is going to do it, no one else is
going to bring articles of impeachment forward,
I'm going to be the one to do so. Honestly,
this is probably the best that we can hope for,
right? Because Republicans rarely ever hold their
own accountable. You know, they're sticking by
Donald Trump despite his criminality, despite
the January 6th insurrection. They're sticking by
George Santos, despite him getting elected on the
basis of countless, countless lies. And they're
also going to let Clarence Thomas presumably get
away with this because they don't actually care
about integrity or rule of law or any of these
other things that they claim to care about, any of
these other supposed principles that they claim to
espouse. I'm Pat Ford filling in for David Packman
today. We'll be back with much more of the David
Pakman show right after this commercial break.